hello everyone grandmaster varakovian
here for our tuesday
lecture on endgames insane in the end
game
and here i prepared the game for you
that is very
very difficult game for me because i was
winning
and this game would have qualified me to
the world cup
but unfortunately i failed to win then i
had to deal with the playoffs which
ended in a draw and then we had to do
the armageddon
and then i managed you know i didn't
manage to go through
and our armageddon was also devastating
because it was dead drone position
i flagged eight moves eight easy moves
away from getting that
increment on move 60 so my my clock ran
out and moved 52
so it was it was devastating so but
anyway
so let's let's start guys hello hello
everyone hello
uh friends and let's begin with this
game okay
some of you might have seen this game
because if you're watching it live
but you might have just seen the game
but now you're going to get the inside
ideas of the game
knight f6 c4 g6 knight c3d5
takes i decided to take and now we have
the grunfeld defense
okay
and knight f3 we have the classical
groomfield setup here
i play bishop e3
at some you know at some point you're
going to see the queens are going to get
swapped off and we're going to be
entering this position so he goes queen
a5
putting pressure on c3 and whenever
opponent plays queen a5
in these positions you need to somehow
block this because
you never want to be in a position where
you make a move like this
an opponent takes and you cannot take
back with the pawn
if you ever have to take back with the
piece here that means you don't have
any advantage okay so that's a very
important thing
for you to remember okay so you don't
want that
so now i go queen d2
castles and rook c1
developing my rook and now keeping
everything protected
and now he played the bishop g4 you know
he
he had some games previously that i knew
that he might play something like this
because it looks like he likes to
you know get this bishop out quickly and
try to apply
uh pressure here and try to do something
here and here
the main theory goes d5 but since i
didn't exactly expect it this way he
would play i didn't
review that the current theory on this
so i decided the best thing for me to do
is to try to
avoid going into the sharp line uh
yeah i could have played knight f3 d2
that's another option
in this position it's a it's it's a
fashionable move but again
uh very very complicated stuff if it
takes on c3
or you can take c takes deep order as
well
uh so we get to the position now since
like i say i didn't i didn't
review the d5 lines so i decided i
should play
bishop p2 and now comes a very strong
move by my opponent
and this move doesn't look very clear
but it's it's a really nice idea it goes
knight d7
developing the knight and now what to do
and now he's threatening some knight b6
ideas and
things not looking that easy for me here
to make a decision because for example
if i castle
takes takes takes on d4
takes on d4 swapping the queens and then
picking up on d4
we pick up the uh the pawn
so this is gonna be good for me
uh sorry so this is gonna be good for
him because i'm losing my central pawn
so that's why um i can't just castle
here so i have to make a decision
uh what to play i was considering the
move uh
d5 but i didn't quite like the move c4
now
because now if you place bishop takes if
i play this he can
take for example he takes
rook ac8 and now pressure
we have a lot of pressure on
c4 and we have bishop bishop c3
um that line i don't know if it's that
good
uh uh autumn arm or m hassan
adam hassan is saying maybe this is okay
but i'm not sure rook c7
[Music]
um
yeah prob probably it will be some some
equality but nothing more than that for
me
uh 95 he can play
i don't think i'll i don't think i'll
have more than more than that here
so and putting pressure on f3 here
so that's why he didn't uh you know i
didn't want to go for this
it's possible i'll probably have some
equality but
you know i wanted to play for the win
here i have the white pieces
i played h3 now my opponent took bishop
to except three and here are very
important here
very important moment here and i have to
make the right decision here
okay how do i take back
how do i take back here i have options
here guys
but you have to you have to calculate
this precisely because
it's not so simple okay
because of course uh we're we want to
take back with the bishop
but we have to calculate what would
happen you know
so what do you think i should do think
about it and you can put in a chat here
i'm watching the chat so how should i
take back here
because it's very important here to play
precise
very important to play this precisely
g takes f3 bishop f3 followed by rook
t895
bishop f3 takes 6 and i think we are
fine
well the problem with bishop f3 guys
it's
it's very concrete here of course if i
can play bishop f3 then i play
you know let's say e5 i'll be fine i'll
be i'll be very happy
but the problem with this is if i take
with the bishop
he goes knight b6
he goes knight b6 and now he's
threatening knight c4
putting pressure on the queen and so now
the question is what do i do
how do i deal with knight c4 threat
let's say
if i castle he just he
he will take my dark score bishop and
yeah i don't i don't have much here
so
of course i can try to play bishop e2
it looks like i'm somehow holding but
here
black plays a very simple line he takes
i take he takes i take he goes rook fd8
and now my d4 pawn is hanging
if you play e5 i go bishop takes e5
taking d4
if you play d5 here then e6 is very very
unpleasant
and now i'm not sure what to do about
this
so that's that's the problem here i i
don't know what to do now with my center
here unfortunately i'm like one move off
i'm one move off from uh
getting a decent position i mean i have
some rook c7 ideas
but he takes
if i take take
k3
excuse me now rook d7
in fact during the game i was
calculating this
now he goes here
thank you thank you
uh yeah i
i don't know i calculated this maybe i
can play like this i mean
it's not it's not out of question okay
i might be able to play like this but
um
then he takes
i take he attacks me because you know
now he's got two pumps hanging so
i'm getting the pawn back here there's
no question there
but i think it's just gonna be a draw
take something
we get we get something like this
and i don't have much here
so i spent a lot of time here
guys it was it was not easy because this
wasn't a preparation
so i had to take back with the g pawn
now he plays e6 because the idea behind
these sixes
he wants to make sure i cannot play d5
because d5 he will take me
and now import the moment here i spend
about 30 minutes here
because i still have a problem with my
center here i can't castle because he
takes
takes and he takes this pawn
so i can't do that so i have to make a
decision and but i found a very very
strong move here
i found a very strong move here guys so
let's see
uh bishop h6 we actually uh uh
david we're not trying to trade the dark
square bishops here because
our advantage consists of the two
bishops if we trade the dark square
bishop then
we don't we don't have that advantage
okay
and in particular here is there's a
concrete problem he takes
text and he takes this and i don't have
a way to recapture now because of the
pin
but it's very important to remember we
don't want to trade the dark square
bishops here
h4 is a move that i consider but i did
not really
find anything great after this and then
in the long run my h4
might be a target you know he will play
bishop f6 and target this
so it may turn out to be a liability for
me
so that's why i didn't play that f4
suggested by autumn
um i thought about it
i definitely did thought about it but
i'm not sure what am i trying to do now
in this position with this move
yeah i think i just go here
all right 595 i don't know
so this this is not not ideal here my
king is still in the middle
um f5 i don't know this is
looks kind of dangerous king is in the
mirror
yeah looks very risky
no i i thought about d5 but then if it
takes i'm not sure what to do actually
seriously consider this line
i even calculated this there's this but
then again
i don't think i'm playing for advantage
here because my king is in the middle
and
i just don't think i'll i'll be able to
be better here i played a very good move
after which my opponent spent
about 30 minutes so we both spent 30
minutes at this moment
when i played this move he realized i'm
gonna get a good setup here
all pawns in black well trade queens
how do we trade queens though i would
like to trade queens
i would love to trade quince here but
the question is how can we do that
the question is how can we achieve that
and again not the right moment to push
the h-pawn because if you go
h-pawn once again i mentioned this
earlier this pawn might become a
weakness later on
to bishop f6 and a target so
queen b2 uh atom it doesn't work he
takes cd
your king is still in the middle see all
kinds of problems because this king is
pinned
so very strong move here
gm move here grand master move here you
have to find
after this move he spent 30 minutes
because you realize
i'm untangling my position okay i am
untangling
rook c2 chess king bravo chess king
that's exactly what i did bravo chess
king
protecting the queen and now solving the
problem now if i castle
if he takes i take back with the pawn
he takes i take back with the rook
okay i take back with the rook with a
very strong position okay
so
arrow kc8
i go rp1
you know here here i wish i would have
played this move a little bit quicker
because i spent another nine minutes
here
i i you know
playing faster sometimes it's important
because you want to preserve your time
for a more important moments here
i mean there's nothing better i have
here so i should have just played
because the reason i didn't play this
quickly enough i was considering
what to do against this
because if it goes here i need to have
some kind of setup here
and uh
the interesting line is bishop g5
hitting the rook
and
here if he goes the 7i bishop b5
trying to chop it but things get kind of
really complicated after cd4
bishop takes d7 he takes on c3 because
now my queen is under attack
my bishop is under attack my bishop is
under attack so it's like a lot of
things that are under attack
yep so it's a chaos here
it's a chaos um everything is hanging
suddenly
and position is complicated
so that's why i
didn't have to play the move bishop d5 i
could have just played the move king g2
and if he takes i take
the queen is under attack if it takes
i take back with the rook
i take back with rook and now i'm
threatening d5 ideas
and i think this is kind of close to
what happened in the game here
but it's interesting my best move here
actually is just king g2
keeping the small advantage somebody
mentioned f6
f6 you never really want to do here
because then i can just come back
and you have significantly weakened the
position of the king
and the light squares are weakened as
well
so that's why we don't we don't
necessarily want to play the move
black doesn't really want to play the
move f6
so that's why you know i guess he didn't
like this bishop g5 line so he took
now i take back and now the question is
here
should he trade queens his queen is
under attack so he has to make a
decision
okay he has to make a decision
so see some people would just play queen
h5 here
quickly and intuitively but if they do
this is a big mistake now
we trade yeah this this is good for
white when they take on d4 it helps
and now imagine i just simply play king
g2 and now
white is just winning it's like the
computer gives this a plus two advantage
for white
first of all we're threatening bishop g5
and f4
and a queen is dropped we also have rook
b5 idea out there so it's
really really nice position for white
so he takes on d2 rook takes d2
rfd8 and now again
critical moment here i need to find a
good plan because
yeah maybe slightly better because i
have the
some center and i have two bishops but
my pawns are also a little bit weak
so he has pressure queen a4 instead of
is good for black i don't think so
i don't think queen a4 is that good here
because you can get chased around by
bishop b5 no
i don't think it's that good
then you gotta move it again
uh actually uh sorry sorry queen a4 uh
my rook is hanging so i have to
there was a move i had i forgot let's
see here
yeah maybe maybe even take maybe even
take first
but i think what he played was the best
because now he goes here and he's like
okay i'm very solid how are you gonna
beat me here
you know you know very very
solid but here i played this this moment
of the game this sequence i think i
played quite well here
so let's think of a plan let's spend
couple of minutes here guys and think of
the right plan here
that we need to do
war is the right plan
so please type in the in in the chat
your the plan you think is the best plum
here because
we have two bishops we have some center
but how to break through
so now rook b6 no
we cannot sacrifice here we need to we
need to
we need to somehow get a 4a5 in
at some point he might play f5 maybe not
immediately christopher
but at some point he might try to get
some control with f5
of course the move that comes to mind is
the move a4
but the problem he takes
and if we take now sorry if we take now
he plays a5
and now knight c3 is coming up and it's
it's it's what do i do with this guy
knight c3 like he go here knight c3
if i move we should be plays f4 a4
okay
so if i take
no i'm not even sure i mean this this
this this could turn into only a little
bit you know
because i might have to figure out the
way to make a draw
if i take it takes i mean
it's not great okay
for me uh
yeah and again i i probably have to play
this but then he plays a4
and you know this this pump can get
really dangerous here i don't think i
need this
so i need to prepare guys i need to
prepare
this a4 how can we prepare that
yeah you could do this but that's just
basically a draw
takes take take
my pawns are too weak i mean i don't
think i can win this position
i think it's just gonna be a draw here
i can play with these six probably my
pawns are just too weak if this pawn was
on g2
maybe i can try to press a little bit
it's still probably gonna be a draw but
here
it's opposite color and i have a weak
pawns as well
all right so how can we prepare bishop
d1
joseph we can't play bishop d1 because
unfortunately
he will hit us with knight c4 tempo
hitting this and hearing that so
it's not gonna be great so instead we're
gonna go bishop 2
b5 correct absolutely bishop b5
controlling the squares
and now getting ready to play that a4
idea
and if he plays a6 guess what we take
he takes we take okay
so can that so he played
rook c7
now we continue with our plan and now he
goes here
now what he's trying to do he's trying
to quietly bring his knight on d6
and that way there's no pressure on b7
and now some ideas
to jump in on c4 and if for example i
play e5
then it's a problem because he goes here
and then he has this wonderful
squares for his knight so this was a
tough moment here i had to spend a
little bit of time
to find a plan because he's he's trying
to regroup his knight and it's going to
be a strong regroup
on my position so what should i do here
what to do here
bishop or bishop f4 here bishop f4 here
he might just play rook c3
and
suddenly we have this guy hanging and
this guy hanging we got two guys hanging
suddenly okay
hello manny hello how to prepare here
we need we need to start thinking about
some
breaks guys we need to open up the
bishop because this pressure on the
forest
is is annoying we constantly have to
worry about this and
so what i decided to do i bring my king
into the game first
and now if let's say he plays knight d6
i have a strong move now
if he plays knight d6
what is the strong move that i have here
if we hit the knight with what with the
pawn now
yeah we could but the best is d5 now
because you open up this bishop correct
some good moves here d5 now you open up
this bishop
now he takes
and i take now threatening a very strong
b6 and it's funny if he takes
if i take back he will play b6 and is
about equal here i don't have much
but when he takes we have a fantastic in
between move here
what is that fantastic in between move
here guys
what is that fantastic in between move
b6 absolutely b6 hitting the rook
hearing the pawn
takes attacks
yeah so that's why you realize there are
some problems here
and if he plays this let's say he plays
ed
i can even take and now that pin could
be very annoying
he can just easily untangle now i have
rook bd1 and
yeah he can't just untangle
so he goes b6
group bd1
doubling up the rooks and again i'm
trying to play this move d5
he played knight d6 by the way he has
been playing very accurately
accurately so far
my opponent is a grandmaster from
argentina 2530 rating uh chris
chrisa crystal last name now
i don't have time for this anymore
bishop a6 because he's going to hit me
with knight c4 idea
so i don't have time for that so i go
here d5
and he played e5 here e5 is a bad move
this is probably his
only big mistake but it's it's really a
big mistake in this position
his best chance was to take and
in general when opponent has two bishops
in any game you have a chance to
eliminate it you should do it
i believe hebrews probably worried about
this move
this is not that bad because take
take and king f8 and here white is a
little bit better but i think with
accurate play block should be able to
hold because
there's just not enough material here on
the board okay
so should be able to hold but i think he
was concerned about me taking dtx e6
and now the rook is hanging so you have
to take take
and now there is a rook d8 threat
which perfect bishop h6 so if let's say
you decide to keep the knight
you just get made it okay
so um he plays
d4 he i think he missed this move
i actually also missed this idea during
the game but it's very very strong
because now if we take in between
if we take on d4 you can just trade and
take only 6.
it should be equal
uh takes sorry
so there is a question if rook takes d2
isn't there
sorry yeah no i don't want to take on f7
now because
i will be down a piece then you can just
move the knight
i don't want to take now on f7
i got to take back first to rook but now
knight d4
take
and the problem is he has this rook f3
and this way he can get the equalizer
okay this way he can get the equalizer
so that's why he had to go for this but
he he just didn't see this side this is
a tricky idea
yeah this is this is a tricky idea in
94.
all right takes
he played e5 yeah this is a this is a
bad move because now i have a permanent
uh you know you know my passpond is
permanent
and i will prepare my a5 break i go here
first
so i can go bishop d3 because now i
needed to have the if he plays f4 i have
a square to retreat on d2
i really want him to play a four so i
can go bishop b2 but he he never did
that
he played this correctly so you double
up and i go a5
creating weaknesses b5 a6
now this is a very big advantage here
for me look
uh bishop f8 rp1 k2
hp7 and here um i i shuffled around a
little bit here maybe this wasn't the
right thing to do
uh i should have just just taken the
pawn
according to the computer and allow him
to take here and put the bishop on c6
and try to convert this position okay
yeah it's a very very good winning
chances here for white
but i thought i can get more so i was
trying to
maneuver and get to the perfect setup
here so next few moves are
unclear if they gave me anything
but we shuffle we
basically we both shuffle we're both
about a minute here
and now i played rook c1
trading one pair of rooks which i think
will help me now i'm putting pressure on
b5
rook b3 everything was done right now
i'm ready to play bishop c3
and then some before ideas he goes here
and now very important moment
now what to do
yeah we're down to one minute here yeah
but this is the right moment now
i traded one pair of rooks we're getting
the 30 second increment though it's not
like
that terrible
okay thanks see you adam good night
all right so what's the idea
yeah i could have maybe played bishop c3
but then he probably plays bishop f6
yeah i wasn't so sure if i gained much
from this
i i just took
now he has to take back on e4
i mean if he takes on b5 i go rook takes
without he takes back now i go bishop c6
and now critical moment here i mean this
is definitely looks
very very close to be winning for me and
i was expecting him to take this way
and i was just gonna take king takes and
then bishop c3 putting pressure i mean
it's very very good winning chances for
me okay
but he played a tricky move not a very
good move but it's a tricky move
and i made the critical mistake here
that cost me the game
so he plays knight c4 here and here i
have two
very simple decision the ways i can win
the game
and i i play the the very natural move
but
it will it will turn out to be a mistake
so what do you think i should do in this
position
why to play take your time a little bit
you can put in a chat here what do you
think i should do here
as a plum
there are two different ways i can play
here
and win
yeah and you guys suggesting the right
stuff i have to do anything but
give up my dark square bishop anything
but give up my dark square bishop okay
if i keep my darks for bishop i'm just
going to win this game okay
there is just not going to be any
questions here about who is winning this
game
so the winning move is rook b7
s1 and number two bishop c3
both of these moves are winning this
game quite easily
and i don't know why i spent only 19
seconds i didn't expect
to move knight c4 because it didn't look
right to me and i thought oh i just take
this pawn
and i can i can convert this i'm up a
pawn and
i'm completely dominating i didn't think
that this would be a problem for me to
win this position
wrong thinking and there was a problem
okay let's start out with rook p7 most
natural move on the board
the problem with this is i did not uh
went deep enough to calculate
like for example if he takes here
i'm winning after this move king to d3
because i'm hitting his knight
if he takes on d2 i take on c7 if it
takes i take back with this and now i
have a promotion here
on the eight okay
and
if he goes bishop d6 in this position
now there is a critical moment here
i have a very very critical moment here
what's the move here without this move
it might not be so clear
so this is this is a tempo game here
bishop b4 absolutely because now you're
threatening to take and go ba
if he takes we go b8 queen so
if he takes and again once again what is
the move if it takes
once again what's the move
king d3 absolutely king d3 hitting the
knight
how did i miss this i win this game i
qualify to the world cup directly guys
it's it's over
um
yeah and if he doesn't take if he
retreats
then we just take we got two bishops
extra pawn
passport on the seventh rank i mean this
is just
i don't win immediately but basically i
will get the king in
pawn f3 and then slowly i can walk my
king to a6 and
take on a7 i mean
slowly but surely i will win this game
okay
so
that was the first idea rp7 just wins
another idea
you know i should have just spent a
little bit more time and then i would
have realized that i need to keep my
bishop here
just bishop c3 was another idea that
wins on the spot
and this is this is probably even
cleaner because now if he takes
most likely he's going to do that
because i'm just taking this guy now
and if he takes i can take
and it's winning but i can play even
stronger than that
king d3 hitting the knight
knight cannot go anywhere active so you
can go d6
then i take and it's completely tangled
up here
and then rook b7 comes in and
threatening bishop d6 through k7
just just just completely winning
resigns
and he can play knight b6
we take take he goes here and now
what is the finishing line here very
easy finish i mean there are many ways
to win here but
what would be the finishing touch here
yeah rook takes p6 takes
a7 and it's it's funny he
might not be even be able to even
sacrifice the rook for the pawn because
i can even play
bishop b8 and get a full queen you know
of course i can just promote and win up
a piece but i can even just play bishop
be that that just simply shows guys how
dominating my position is right now okay
yeah this was this was like yeah this
basically ends the game if i play bishop
c3
i don't think the game is gonna last
that much longer here guys there's just
no way for him to
do anything i mean he could
he could maybe try this bishop d6 and
now it's interesting i just take let's
say he goes here
i just go up he goes here
there there are many ways i can try to
win this game
but easiest is just this bishop here pin
it
he defends it
take take
and now i need to play a7 but i can't
but i can try this
beautiful interpose here beautiful
interpose
and now i'm just gonna push and once
again
we see that this is
simply a resignation
there are many other ways i can win here
i can win by going here
and here and here
and here i mean it's just completely
winning
yeah i i mean rugby seven is winning but
i think bishop c3 is just just
even even cleaner
even cleaner than move bishop c3 would
have been
so anyway i missed that i i took i don't
know why
i did that now he took took and here he
missed
he missed a good move here he actually
played bishop g5 which gave me a good
winning chances again
but black has a very strong defensive
move here guys
black has a very strong defensive move
here that he needs to play
what do you think
because my threat is to play rook b8
my threat is to play rook b8
bishop d6 yes and now i cannot do
anything about it because now if i play
rook b8
the problem is he has a tactic
i really need to have my rook if i want
to win this game but i can't now
because of the tactic that he has do you
guys see the tactic he has here
no rp7 it's opposite color in game is
draw
many most likely a draw
rook takes bishop yes and if i take back
he takes me here there we go
and if check i'll just go to c7
now just up a piece
uh for black so after bishop d6 he would
have some good
drawing chances here but he played here
i went here
and i'm very close now i'm like
that's why during the game i didn't
think this would be that hard to win i
thought i'm just dominating here i
should be able to win
but he gets the king in there i go here
now i go here i thought you know i'm
gonna be able to win this way you know
when this pawn but again he finds the
only move here
yeah he found a lot of he defended well
guys because he found a lot of only
moves here
now i'm looking back i mean he he had to
find a lot of tough moves like here
it looks like i'm just going to go
bishop
bishop to b7 and win the a pawn once i
win the a pawn it's again this game is
over
but once again he came up with the very
decent response
what is the only move here for him
so when i go bishop b7 he has a defense
okay congratulations at two that's a
great great accomplishment
20 points uh bishop d8 you can't i have
rook takes d8
no rook f2 is losing rook a7 antonio
you cannot lose the you cannot lose the
a7
you have to figure out the way that you
can defend the a7
bishop h4 yep
yep now i went here and now he goes here
i mean good defense by him no
no question good defense i go here
uh now i'm winning i'm winning here but
i had to find rook d8
it's not as easy but it's winning check
has to go here
because if he goes here guys i just
simply go check
he goes away check and then i take this
pawn then
i have two connected pass spawn this is
just winning
so he will breaking c7 now i go here
i'm giving up a pawn
yeah it gets a little complicated then
i'll give up another pawn
and i go here but the problem for him
now is
first of all i i want to go king b4 and
bishop b5 mate
so i have a mating threat here king
before bishop b5 so he has to do
something like
maybe this to try to get out but then i
just simply push
deeper and win the game
yeah this was already a little bit hard
to find you know to give up the pawn so
i didn't want to give up the pawn
i thought eventually he will cracks i
mean i will get the bishop in and
it's got to crack here but he played
very well
in in this defense and again now this is
my second win here right here
this is my last chance here i mean here
i have another win here
a very very nice win i have here guys
but this is hard to find the the idea
here
i would like to play king c5 king c5 and
d6
but i can't because he has bishop e3
but here's a bishop e3 check
so what can i do
yep f4 you're right guys yep this was
the win because now if he takes with
this pawn
then we go king c5 and d6
if he if he goes here only move then we
go
check if he goes back we can even take
on a7 and win if it goes here
check what do we do
what is the idea here
yep group takes e7
d6 win the rook and the game here
goodbye
so he has to take back with the bishop
which probably would have done
but then i have rook f6 and now i'm
threatening d6 check winning the rook
now he goes here
check he cannot go back to c7 i go
d6 he goes here now we push
rook has only one square to go to we
push now he goes here and now
there are a few different ways to win as
you can see the arrows indicating rookie
6 rook 8 wins
but you can play even better than that
you can play more beautiful than that
here
yep rook takes f6
takes e5
perfect push
and now he wants to go f1 queen
we simply play king c5 and we're
controlling that
and now e7 coming we're gonna have a
full queen here here we just go bishop
e2
or bishop d3 just and my pawns are
simply
unstoppable guys he goes here
king d6 e7 this was another win but it
was already hard
harder to find this and i haven't played
chess in about a year and a half this
was my first tournament after
you know all the pandemics so that's why
it was it was a bit tough i
wasn't definitely playing my best but
still i thought the level was not bad
you know the all the ideas thinking was
not bad
um yeah it's it's it's they both win
i mean i don't know if you don't want to
calculate you just go here and just
go here i mean this is just the
elementary win you just take
it's more fancy yeah i will make some
check perk
lectures at some point that's that's you
know i haven't played that many new
games so i don't have
some new stuff to to include and then
keep on is simply winning here
so yeah and let me show you what
happened here how the game ended in a
draw because
here i didn't see f4 i still tried to
win hard
i've been back here i was i was hoping
that i can maybe trick him into like
uh like right now i go here and not
winning the pawn so if he goes bishop h4
i can go ke2 maybe
so he goes here here
and i go here and here here i played a
really bad move here i should have just
played rookie 8 here and still keep my
winning chances i play rook d6
check in my mind i thought i'm making
progress here because now if he goes
here
i go here in my mind i thought you know
i can now bring the bishop back and my
rook
rook is active and if he goes here
i can go check
and i have some opportunities to advance
my pawn
yeah well well i made it tricky if i
didn't give him my dark square bishop
or i don't know if you saw it earlier it
was it was just the easy win
so yeah i went here and now i play the
great move king b4 and now
suddenly my my pieces are stuck he's
ready to play rook c3
i saw this and originally i thought oh
i'll shut him down with this
but when i was about to play this i
realized wait a minute he's got this
now my rook is trapped and if i trade
rooks i'm now i'm not going to win this
game
i can't afford trading i should have
done it but
you know i didn't do it but i should
have done it because now here
he goes here i can if i go here he
trades here he
trades i lose a bishop and here he goes
here now suddenly
i have f3 hanging and i'm losing my pawn
so that doesn't work but at least i
should have attempted this
i mean it's a draw of course but i
should have
attempted this idea
last trick you know if it takes maybe i
can try to win this position
i'm not sure if i can but
maybe maybe uh
maybe i can go here actually maybe this
is spinning can i have d6
yeah but anyway this is a draw because
of this move
and now he just goes king d6
so if it goes here just takes
i'm just gonna see here
now that i can't really break through
here
uh yeah so so i i took the pawn and now
he played a very precise move bishop f4
attacking my rook rook goes back and now
he gets a perpetual
i'm right one move behind from shutting
down this
this rook here check check
i went back check and again i have to be
careful here you can get made it here
can d3 it's actually a mate
of course i should have never allow him
to get this activity you know
i mean when i had him in this position
for his he's barely hanging on to this
but somehow he does hang it on which was
amazing
he had a seven weakness and i could not
win
so yeah opposite color bishop is tricky
and that's how the game ended in a draw
here
all right guys i hope you enjoyed this
game this is a very heartbreaking game
because like i say if i win this game i
qualified to the world cup
and you can see i was like basically one
move away
from winning it all i had to do here is
just keep my dark square bishop here
again
just bishop c3 and the game is over here
so but anyway you learn you know we
always learn
we always learn from this kind of games
we realize that wait a minute
we gotta keep the bishops okay
he defended very well yeah kudos kudos
to him he defended really well no
question about that a lot of people
including grandmasters would have
cracked you know but he he
you know he he played a tricky move
knight c4 it's a very good practical
move i mean it's losing move
but again it you know it's it's confused
me a little bit
and i made a quick decision i only spent
19 seconds here i should have done a
little bit more
but anyway yeah i should have just done
this
bishop c3 and the game is over well
thank you very much guys for
you know watching this video i
appreciate you being here
i will be back on thursday for two more
two more
lectures remember thursday is a big
lecture day so we start at 6 30
to 7 30 and then 7 30 to 8 30 make sure
you come in
on thursday okay all right
thank you guys and looking forward to
seeing you in two days
bye bye
you